Speaker 1: Jorge Santos stole a disabled
veterans dogs charity money, and the dog died.
Let that sink in, folks. Report from Patch dot
com. Disabled veteran Jorge Santos took $3,000.
From dying dogs. Go fund me. This one is even
worse than it sounds, if you can believe it. Two
New Jersey veterans. Veterans say George Santos
promised to raise funds for a life saving surgery
for a service dog and then disappeared. Report
out of Queens In May 2016, Richard Ostroff was
living in a tent in an abandoned chicken coop on
the side of Route nine and Howell, New Jersey,
with his beloved service dog, Sapphire. A
veteran's charity gave the pit mix to Ostroff,
who's a disabled veteran, honorably discharged
from the Navy. Sapphire, the dog, developed a
life threatening stomach tumor. Our staff learned
the surgery would cost $3,000, a vet tech said to
staff. I know a guy who runs a pet charity who can
help you. That guy was Anthony devoted there. Now,
at this point, you might know Anthony Duvall.
There is the name George Santos used to use.
So we're talking about George Santos. The pet
charity was called Friends of Pets, United Oak,
Ostroff, and another New Jersey vet,
retired Police Sergeant Michael Bull,
tried to intervene to help. Asked off in 2016,
told Patch, Hey, you know what Devil dare? We'll
call them Santos. That's how we know him. Santos
closed the Go Fund me. He set up for Sapphire
after it raised $3,000 on social media, but then
disappeared. Ostroff said he stopped answering my
texts and calls. He posted to Facebook in 2016 to
everyone who helped me, and Sapphire raised the
money for her surgery. I'm sorry to say we were
scammed by Anthony to older. Through a series of
bad veterinary contacts and subterfuge regarding
payment. Sapphire has not received vet care. Her
growth is 3 to 4 times bigger than it was when the
campaign was fulfilled. She is facing euthanasia
within months. Sapphire indeed died January
15th of 2017. After being out of work with a
broken leg for over a year, our staff couldn't
even afford the dogs euthanasia and cremation.
He had to panhandle for it, which he called one
of the most degrading things he ever had to do.
I contacted Santos and told him, You're
messing with a vet. Give the money back
or use it to get us to have another dog. He was
totally uncooperative on the phone, said Bull.
I can see why this guy loves Trump. I can see
why this guy loves Trump. This is way worse
than the headline even makes it sound. And this
is the guy, George Santos, Anthony Davis, older,
who has now been assigned to multiple committees,
the House of Representatives. And apparently, I
don't know, but apparently is going to be able to
weather the media storm and stick around for two
years. Despite being one of the most disgusting
individuals I've learned about in all of my time
covering American and world politics. I am losing
faith that he is going to be removed. I. He's
just he's just sticking around. And particularly
now with committee assignments. It doesn't seem
like Republicans and Kevin McCarthy have any
interest in forcing him out. For all we know,
and as the speculation is is growing, McCarthy
and Santo struck a deal. Santos supports McCarthy
for speaker. McCarthy doesn't try to push
him out. And of course, the support of the
speaker is a very powerful thing for a member of
Congress, particularly a new one. Where will this
end? What will we next learn about Jorge Santos?
Anthony Day Bolder. Let me know in the comments.
Make sure you subscribe it on YouTube. And of
course, all of the clips I played for you in
this segment and earlier segments are available on
our YouTube channel as well as on our Instagram.